all right well Congressman Quan cisman
is back with us and we'll we got you
back all right Congressman before we
left you and this Tech issue happened
you laid out a case for why you thought
secretary meus should be impeached there
are a few holdouts though on the
Republican side um
why well that that's a good question for
them I mean you look at the evidence and
and he's he needs to go the numbers are
on the rise over 31,000 Street releases
in southern in Arizona since September
13th of last year the numbers continue
to grow uh no progress has been made the
waves are up and down uh the Tucson
sector has been several weeks the top
sector in the entire Southern Border in
the entire country on both sides of the
border and there's there's no sign of
slowing down or him having any intention
of doing his job clear that he has uh
that he has willfully and intentionally
not applied the law and he has lost the
trust of the American people so
Alejandra mayorcas needs to be impeached
and I will be supporting that uh quite
Ferb as well well your area is being
affected um so intensely you know a lot
of our viewers just wonder why why is
Joe Biden doing there's lots doing this
there's lots of theories I know you've
put a lot of thought to this um it's
happening in your District um the
effects of it why do you think Joe Biden
has opened the border and and enabled um
this Invasion
truly you know initially you would think
that it was incompetence and then after
you know three years of this I I don't
think you you could just put it all in
just plain incompetence of this he
started out by uh stopping a lot of the
things that were working on day one he
wanted to make a political statement out
of this Sanctuary cities were putting
out statements of welcoming migrants and
so on But when reality hits when rubber
hits the road everybody sees that that
this isn't working and even now Democrat
Mayors from across the country are
coming to their census and really seeing
the results of sanctuary cities and the
policies that they've supported for so
many years but it doesn't seem like Joe
Biden is is getting the message on that
and I'm not sure why that's happening
I'll tell you what for years now
Democrats in my district Republican
Mayors Democrat Mayors supervisors law
enforcement it it's had a bipartisan
support on border security it it's not
until recently that some Democrats are
coming along on the national level but
still no action from the president or
Alejandra mayorcas so going back to the
previous Point that's why mayorcas needs
to be impeached immediately yeah D
eltion of Duty no doubt be interesting
to see who those hold outs are we'll try
and dig into that we'll also be digging
into the NGS who are clearly profiting
off of this um so I'm Steve duy I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis